this is a major transition area moment
how have you seen that evolution of
civilization up until this point of
synthetic biology well it's a obviously
big question but I think one of the
things that that critics often point out
is we make mistakes and there's no doubt
about it we are a species of engineers
that is that as both our that's our past
and our future is almost certainly has
to do with our unique ability to really
think deeply about the past in the
future into engineer as a consequence we
we do make mistakes but we're probably
only species that is capable of
protecting any or all of the species
from catastrophic events like asteroids
the Sun expansion etc so we have that
responsibility to ourselves and many
other species and maybe to the whole
universe we there is still yet an open
question as to whether we're the only
intelligence in in the entire universe I
mean it's it's arrogant to think of it
either way
that were the that we're the only one or
that were one of a billion you know it's
it's just it's arrogant to think we know
the answer that